hello everyone and welcome back with
another game from the 2017 world rapid
championship this game is played between
everyone's favorite Vasiliev on Chuck is
playing against sorry a shocker Ganguly
of India and in case some of you forgot
even chuck is actually the 2016 rapid
world champion the championship was
played last year in Qatar Doha and in
the end von Schuch district and the
Magnus Carlsen both had I mean all three
of them had 11 points out of 15 but in
the tiebreaks
vastly a bunch of won first place very
strip second and Magnus Carlsen got
third place so I'm very interested to
see how vastly one chip will do in this
world rapid championship also in blitz
and as I'm making this video so far he
played only three games he won one game
and two of the games were drawn but
we'll see how it goes
he will play two more games today and
tomorrow will be the end of the rapid
until the blood section starts so let's
see this game he has the white pieces
against the Indian Grand Master - a car
Ganguly and he plays c4 again we have
been which opening like in the Carlson
game we had 'if I've g3 and knife to f6
Bishop to g2 d5c captures Knight
captures and Knight to f3 Knight to c6
eventual castles we have night to b6 d3
Bishop to e7 Knight bTW - Ganguly
castles and a3 a5 b3 rook to e8 and
Bishop to b2 are going for the e5 pawn
we have a bishop to f8 not the rook is
protecting d5 pawn and Knight to c4 we
have Knight captures beat captures and
9th to d4 and this night to d4 was
actually well it's a it's a kind of a
tactical inaccuracy probably a better
idea would be to push maybe a a for to
you know force this 83 pawn to stay on a
dark square but this is you know too far
into the future for a rapid game but
okay 94 was played Knight captures on e5
by von Schuch
and maybe best would be to leave this
925 as it is and probably just developed
with Bishop to c5 and you know pretend
like you sacrificed this pawn but none
really captures the knight and rook
captures only five and we have III and
see if I was played here the problem is
you can't play Knight to c6 with the
idea of Bishop captures then you
recapture the bishop and you got two
pieces for a rook the problem is first
this Bishop will capture the night and
only then will this Bishop capture the
rook so instead c5 was played and now
rook to e1 still this knife can't move
Bishop to a5 was played and now you
magic captures the knight we have pawn
captures rook captures only one Queen
characters and C captures on d4 so the
material is equal but there there is
some merit to doing matrix position the
isolated d4 pawn could become a weakness
but we'll see Queen to d2 why vine choke
and Bishop to c5 and again if black
chose to push a four at any given moment
it would probably be okay
simply you know making this pawn stay on
a3 it could become a target rook to e1
even took puts a rock on the open file
we have Queen to b6 and rook to e5 now
attacking the bishop Bishop to e6 and a4
now now we want to permanently pushes
that pawn to e4 and now it will no
longer be a target rook the c8 and we
have Bishop to d5 Bishop captures rook
captures and to Rob to e8 came to g2 not
allowing any future rook to e1 ideas
with check also the king is it's his say
Ferengi to improving the position of the
King also favors white in the endgame
we have h6 ganguly makes some breathing
room for the King so no back rank ideas
can happen Queen to f4 now now there's a
triple attack on the d4 pawn rook to d8
stops this now we have ropes to f5
moving for the f7 pawn rook to d7
defending and now Bishop to c1 rook to
e7 and we have Bishop to d2
not allowing any infiltration with rook
to e1 also there are some tactical ideas
of grabbing the a5 pawn queen to c6
check and the Queen to f3 now we want to
offers the the exchange of Queens
if Ganguly decided to do this Queen
character screen captures it's it's it's
an endgame that really favorite Savannah
took his King is slightly better placed
the rook the rook is a bit more active
attacking the bishop the bishop can't
really move the a5 Bishop is attacked ok
you can play b6 but then always you have
this option of capturing an e5 n a5 and
but even if you don't you know go into
this tactically simply black has all of
his pawns on dark squares this point
will eventually have to be pushed to b6
and eventually has dark square bishop so
these pawns will be targets and divine
chips pawns are all on light squares so
this again favors white so after this
Queen to f3
Ganguly decides not to trade Queen's
Queen to c7 was played but now comes
Queen to d5 the thread is of course
capturing the Bishop on c5 Ganguly plays
b6 but now simply Bishop captures on a
five if you recapture the Bishop sorry
if you if you capture the bishop then
Queen captures Bishop on c5 so g6 was
played attacking the rook now roof to f6
and again if you capture the bishop then
rook rook comes the c6 attacks the
bishop attacks the Queen and eventually
will win back the piece so rook to d7
attacking the Queen but now if I shook
as this rook captures on g6 probably
Ganguly miss this King to f8 and now
rook to c6 if if
wrote capture screen then Brooke capture
screen and all is well we have Queen to
a 7r up the c8 check King to g7 and now
Queen to e5 check f6 is played and after
Queen to e8 Surya Shekhar Ganguly
resigned to the game as there is no
defense against Queen to g8
checkmate yeah you could you know
prolong the game but there's really no
point play something like Bishop f8
simply to allow your King to escape
being captures with check King g6 but to
the simple
32-year down a piece you will lose this
game as black
so after this Queen to eight move
Ganguly resigned to the game and Vasily
is two he has two points out of three
games not a bad result two more games to
go today and like I said I'm very
interested to see how vastly will do in
this year's world a rapid championship
so that's it that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon